We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David Pakman. Here are some
really basic questions about Kuhnen that I
myself have been asking the question regarding.
Q and on. I still don't fully understand.
I mean, from what we know, I mean either one
person account or multiple people from one
account, how is it that this person hasn't
been exposed, that he says he's a government
insider? Yeah.
You believe that the FBI is actually investigating
who this person is, how this so started, you
know, and where the responsibility lies as
far as holding this person accountable for.
I have no idea. These are the questions I've
been I I get the idea that some people think
Q might be Trump. Some people believe Q is
a group of people. Others believe Q is an
individual. How does Q communicate? I guess
originally it was via 4chan, but more recently
it's something else. It's as incoherent to
me as it is to you and to many of the people
in our audience. And I don't know if we'll
ever get the answers to the questions that
are being asked, but they are good questions.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
And Steve AXA's briefly were able to shut
down Dodger stadiums vaccination site over
the weekend. It's actually insane what's going
on with the anti-tax movement in the United
States. The number of hate groups declined
in twenty twenty, but the number of hate incidents
went up. That's an interesting series of facts
that we're going to discuss. And we will also
talk about this situation between Vice President
Kamala Harris and Democratic Senator Joe Manchin,
who is the most conservative Democratic senator
in the U.S. Senate. What's going on with the
two of them? We will discuss that and much,
much more on today's bonus show. Get instant
access, instant. Truly, the speed of light
access to the bonus show by becoming a member
at Join Pakman dot com. You can use the coupon
code better.